one person in particular has made it
clear that he won't be watching if there
is kneeling during the anthem now this
all came up over the weekend in the
context of u.s soccer
changing the rule that was put in place
in 2017
when megan rapino
took a knee in support of colin
kaepernick u.s soccer put in a rule
saying thou shalt stand during the
anthem that rule's gone some politicians
have reacted to that angrily the
president retweeted a message from jim
jordan jim jordan said let's get this
straight united states soccer won't
stand for the united states national
anthem
trump retweeted that and said and it
looks like the nfl is heading in that
direction also but not with me watching
the latest salvo in the fight that was
renewed nine days ago when drew brees
made it clear to the president engaged
the president on this issue the
commissioner's video from nine nights
ago made it clear where the nfl stands
the president has taken a couple of
swipes at the nfl since then that's the
most recent one the nfl has not engaged
him on that one i think they're just
going to ignore
any of that noise going forward and just
focus on doing what they think needs to
be done
and if the drum is going to be banged by
the president over and over and over
again i think the nfl is just going to
go about its business they're not going
to now there may be players that from
time to time will
will specifically direct a message to
him but i think the nfl and the teams
are going to try to not engage him on
this but also at the same time i feel
like there's not going to be wavering
in this position that we saw expressed
by j.j watt baker mayfield and bill
o'brien that there will be kneeling
during the anthem no matter who doesn't
like it yeah well let's let's not blink
an eye at these type of people again
yeah i mean i'm sorry but the president
and you know representative jim jordan
they're they're not in the good fight
here they're not and the nfl needs to
stay strong with its stance because it's
the right thing to do for american
society and of course
it's a league that does not exist
without black people so that is uh two
huge factors but more importantly the
time has come to yes you know again
let's just stay keep going forward nfl
players nfl the league everything don't
worry don't get in uh you know
uh a a a spat with the president or
anybody uh you know in in congress at
this point you know i have an issue with
what jim jordan said there yeah yes the
united states soccer team is not going
to stand for the united states national
anthem because guys like you who are the
united states house of representatives
sometimes don't stand with the rest of
america and fight the things that are
really going on here in this country so
that's why people are going to kneel
because you won't stand up
representative jim jordan and you have
your own issues so i'm sorry but i just
that's where i feel about that i don't
mean to get too crazy here but he takes
a shot at players and athletes he's he's
opened himself to take take some shots
too
here's the thing and this became clear
in the example
that was set by drew brees 12 days ago
you can't stake out middle ground on
this it's one side or the other
and
there is no in between there is no fence
to straddle and so you know as people
bristle at the idea that politics are
invading their sport and frankly they
only don't like politics invading their
sport when it's political viewpoints
they disagree with when it's political
viewpoints they agree with it's
perfectly fine it's just the ones they
don't like that invade their comfort as
someone articulated last week it takes
away my place of comfort only when it's
a political viewpoint that makes you
uncomfortable that makes you
think maybe you should re assess the way
you view things that's when people get
uncomfortable they don't want to have to
deal with that when they're escaping but
as long as they agree with it it's fine
the problem is the two roads are coming
together here as the president makes it
more clear that he is staunchly against
kneeling during the anthem we already
knew that but as he continues to remind
everyone of that and people of his
mindset remind everyone of that and more
and more players and now a head coach
are joining in the notion that
kneeling is not disrespect kneeling is
sending a different message it's
inevitable that that the two are going
to come together and we saw the comments
from greg popovich to marine dow to the
new york times over the weekend that
illustrate it's unavoidable that if you
take a stand for kneeling you eventually
are going to be on the wrong side of the
president and popovich very very strong
in his criticism of the commissioner for
getting intimidated by the president
several years ago and also criticizing
the owners who support president trump
and there are seven or eight owners that
contributed a million dollars to the
inauguration committee four years ago
and it's hard to reconcile that now in
this moment when it's clear where the
president stands this isn't this isn't
on all issues who do you vote for who do
you support referendum this is there's
one very important issue right now to
the majority if not every nfl player and
it's important to fans it's important to
coaches it's important to teams and the
league has said it's important to us
generally the video from roger goodell
makes it clear it's important to us and
when the president is taking positions
and saying things that shows he doesn't
support that he doesn't support the
peaceful protests he hasn't said the
things that would mesh with where the
nfl is then it is impossible to
reconcile the two if you're part of the
nfl and these things are important to
the nfl how do you support the person
who is saying and doing things that are
antithetical to what the nfl is trying
to support so it necessarily becomes
political at that point and it
necessarily becomes fair to say
why do you wait a minute why are you
supporting the person who opposes
everything that the nfl is currently
trying to do
right i mean well agreed i mean yeah yes
that that's exactly the point you know
and we'll see what happens this time
around i mean there better not be any
nfl owners giving donald trump and uh
you know his campaign a million dollars
this time around you're going to have a
true revolt within the nfl if that's the
the you know the issue or what if that
really does happen i mean again you know
just like any like worker they would
like to know that the person that's
employing them you know shares some of
the more same moral integrity and
is in the fight with them with some of
the issues and injustices that are going
on in the world and i think that first
is first and foremost why some players
are a little you know frustrated with
the lack of leadership from ownership
the first time around was different
you know you can give the owners a pass
to a degree
you know did we we just donald trump we
didn't know exactly or some people
didn't want to buy and do exactly what
he was at that time quite yet and i also
think owners were donating money to just
like hey president mr president just
stay away from the nfl here's some money
let us be we don't want to start a
controversy or a fight
but now that's in too deep and i think
everybody's going to be looking to see
if these owners are donating money this
time around and if they are they're
going to have big issues in in in in
their lap here and i just don't i can't
imagine that they would make that
mistake again
the limits
on
donation
that is made to a candidate are like 2
800 the big ticket items come when there
are
contributions made to political action
committees or super pacs and then the
inauguration after the fact so we've got
two different waves here and i think
what and i'm sure people will be keeping
a close eye on contributions made by nfl
owners the companies they own or operate
to these political action committees in
advance of the election and then on the
back end if the president wins
re-election the donations made to the
second inauguration and you're right
those kinds of things will i think be a
hell of a lot more noticed and a lot
more controversial this time around and
it also comes down
to what active visible support are you
going to provide
the president in advance of the election
given these current issues it's it's
going to be
interesting to see it's going to be a
fair question to ask and you know this
is different than invading the rights
that everyone has when they go to the
ballot box that is a private place and
who you ultimately vote for is a private
matter but if you are going to openly
support someone and if it's someone who
is taking views that oppose what the nfl
is trying to do then it becomes a fair
subject for criticism and greg popovich
unloading on that point on sunday in the
new york times
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports